Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number 25 where we're now going to move on
to looking at self-awareness as a trader.
Now, self-awareness is very important
because for retail traders you don't have
a risk manager in your office or at home.
You don't essentially have a boss who is
measuring your abilities as a trader and
also identifying your strengths and
weaknesses. Now, why would a boss do this
at an investment bank or a hedge fund?
Well, professional traders would have risk
managers and bosses to identify whether
more capital should be deployed to those
traders or for capital to be taken away
from them.
As a retail trader, you don't have this.
You have to decide yourself how much
capital you should be deploying to
yourself and when to deploy it. So, what
you need really is a way to measure
yourself as to whether you should be
deploying more capital or less capital and
also ways to measure your strengths and
weaknesses.
So, at least you know that you can deploy
what you need to work on in terms of your
weaknesses. So, professional traders have
the luxury of this and retail traders
don't have this. And this is one of the
main problems because people don't really
know what their own abilities are and
overall whether they should be deploying
more or less capital to themselves.
So, what we are going to do now is go over
to the presentation and show you a pretty
industry standard metric called the Kelly
Criterion. And we are also going to go on
the computer during that process, during
that presentation and I am going to show
you what it really means. So, we will go
through the numbers of a theoretical
trader.
Also, you have the spreadsheet as a
download and you should download this and
go through the numbers so you can
understand how the formula works. So,
let's go over to the presentation and over
to the computer screen and I will see you
at the end of video 25 with a full summary
of the Kelly Criterion.
Okay, we are going to move on to something
called the Kelly Criterion.
So, we have touched on this idea that when
we are winning, we want to be seeking more
risk.
And we have touched on the idea that when
we are losing, we want to be seeking less
risk. We want to be pulling from box B.
So, box A when winning, box B when losing.
But what if we looked over all of our
trades in the past?
We looked at our track record and we
actually started to look at what type of
trader we are.
What we want to have is self-awareness so
we know what type of trader we are.
One of the problems with retail traders is
that they don't have a boss.
So, you don't have anybody to tell you
whether you are any good or not.
So, you don't know whether to have more
capital or take away capital from
yourself.
So, what would a hedge fund manager do if
he had a portfolio of eight traders and
three of them were making money and five
were losing?
What would a hedge fund manager do?
Well, to the hedge fund manager those guys
who are losing money are just losing
positions in the portfolio of traders.
A hedge fund manager doesn't trade stocks,
indices, currencies, commodities.
A hedge fund manager who has traders
working for them trades their traders as
positions.
Hedge fund managers trade humans or
hopefully non-humans.
What does a funds of fund manager do?
Trades humans that trades humans.
Go and speak to a funds of fund manager
and ask them what they do.
In a nutshell, they'll say I trade humans
that trade humans.
It's what they do.
The only problem is retail traders, you
guys, you don't have anybody to tell you
whether you are any good or not.
How much capital to deploy to you, how
much capital to take away from you, when
to do it, etc, etc.
But what you can do is use the same
processes, the same tools that a lot of
hedge fund managers use to have
self-awareness and basically tell you
whether you're any good or not.
So it's just having self-awareness and not
just whether you're any good or not, but
what you're good at and what you're bad
at.
And you work on the things that you're bad
One thing that's going to tell you whether
you're any good or not, which is pretty
damn obvious, is whether you make money or
not.
But if you're making money, it's a mix of
things, of behaviours, of what you're good
at and what you're bad at.
And in overall terms, whether you deserve
more capital and if you do, how much and
when you should deploy it.
So we're going to look at the Kelly
Criterion, a bit of self-awareness.
So based on your trading performance, the
Kelly Criterion just basically tells you
how much you should be committing in
capital terms to your next trade.
It started in the 1950s on the horse
racing track.
Gamblers used to use it when they went to
the horses, to the racetrack.
So they go to the racetrack with $100 and
they go on race one.
Well, let's put the question out there.
If you go to the racetrack with $100 and
there's 10 races today, how much do you
put on race number one?
Okay, so you lose your $10, how much do
you put on race number two?
Yeah, so what you're doing is you're
taking capital away from yourself for each
trade, yeah?
In the reverse, walk onto the racetrack
with $100, you put $10 on and your horse
comes in.
And you make a total of $18.
What would you do next?
Yeah, what would you do next?
Yeah, you take more risk, yeah?
So the Kelly Criterion basically, what
would you do next?
How much do you put on race number three?
Yeah, so what you're doing is you're
taking capital away from yourself for each
trade, yeah?
In the reverse, walk onto the racetrack
with $100, you put $10 on and your horse
comes in.
And you make a total of $18.
What would you do next?
Yeah, you take more risk, yeah?
So the Kelly Criterion basically rewards
traders who make money by saying you put
more capital on your next trade and takes
capital away from traders who always lose.
The marginal rate that you take off and
put on.
That's what Kelly tells you to do, yeah?
But it's a great litmus test when you look
back at your last say 50, 60 trades, what
type of trader you are.
So let's just have a look at an example.
So we've got here a theoretical trader
who's done 60 trades.
On trade one, this trader made $5,000 and
it's a win.
So a one goes in the win score.
On trade number two, this trader made a
loss of $5,000.
So a one goes in the loss score.
So, so far the trader's made no money.
And they've got a win ratio of 50% and a
loss ratio of 50%.
Yeah?
You keep going all the way down.
And we've got the results here.
So the trader on their winners has made
$272,000.
On their losers, the trader has lost
$148,000.
They've made money on 30, they've won on
30 of the trades.
Made money on 30.
Lost money on 30.
So win ratio of 50, loss ratio of 50.
Is that a good trader?
So basically, the Kelly criterion says
that on the next trade, this trader should
put on 23% of their exposure on the next
trade.
23% of their money on the next trade.
Is that sensible?
So over 60 trades, this trader's got 50%
of them right, 50% wrong.
They've made 272 on their winners, lost
148 on their losers.
The ratio between money made on winners
and money lost on losers, 1.84.
And the Kelly criterion says 23% of your
money on the next trade.
So first of all, is this trader any good?
Who says yes?
Who thinks this trader's bad?
Who thinks this trader's just average?
Okay.
The answer is this trader's pretty damn
hot.
What is W?
What is W and what is R?
W is the ability of the trader to generate
ideas and time them well.
Yeah?
Is 50% any good?
It's good.
What is R?
R is the ability of the trader to manage
risk.
Because they can have lots of good ideas.
But if they don't run their winners and
don't cut their losers, their R is going
to be awful.
That's a good R.
Anything around 2 plus is great.
Over a good size number of trades.
So if you look back over your first year
and you've done 60 trades and your win
rate is 50, your loss rate is 50.
And your R is 1.84 plus if it's too
amazing, you're doing well.
So you're obviously making money, you've
got good ideas, you're timing them quite
well, and you've got good risk management.
Now what happens as a hedge fund manager
if you're sitting in the back and you've
got a team of 20 traders and you've got
every trader's spreadsheet with their last
500 trades.
And you're charting in the spreadsheet as
well, you're charting that every trader's
W, every trader's R, their profit and
loss, and they're all on one chart.
And they're moving in real time.
And you see traders who were really,
really good starting to become bad.
really bad starting to become good.
What do you do?
You take money from the guys who are
starting to get bad and give it to the
guys who are starting to do well.
Now it's not 100% scientific, but that's
an example of what hedge fund managers do.
So they'll actually be charting the
performance of their humans.
Does that make sense?
Now back to this issue of 23% in your
portfolio.
That's a very high number to have one
position making a contribution to that in
your portfolio.
But what does that say, for example, if
you put a limit on it and say you start
off with a position that's between 5% and
10% of your portfolio and it starts to
show that it's a big winner in the
portfolio.
What do you do?
You add to it.
Now what happens if originally your single
asset position limit was 10%?
Your single stock position limit was 10%.
Should you be adding to it?
If adding to it means you're going over
your self-imposed 10% position limit,
should you add to it?
No, you absolutely should.
Because Kelly's telling you you're allowed
to.
You're a good trader.
In this situation, you can have comfort
that you're pretty good and you know what
you're doing in pretty much every
situation.
Because the last 60 trades says, as a
trader, you know when to add to winners
and you know when to cut losers.
What would that mean if you were working
at a bank or a hedge fund, it would mean
you'd have to go and see your boss and ask
for permission to do it.
I really want to add to this winner.
Can I increase, can I break my single
stock position limit?
Absolutely.
Go over by 5% for the moment.
Now what happens if it goes in your favour
more?
What do you do?
You go and ask your boss permission to add
more.
And you keep pulling from box A.
And you keep rolling your stop loss until
you get stopped out.
And what will happen once or twice every
year, when you start off with your single
position limits of say 10%.
And those winners start to appear.
And your history as a trader says, you
know what to do on your winners and you
know what to do on your losers.
So you can take comfort in your, in your
track record that you know what you're
doing.
One or two of those trades per year is
going to pay you 50% of all your money for
the year.
Because you're going to go from 10 to 15%
and it'll continue.
You go from 15 to 20% and you'll continue.
And you'll keep rolling your stop loss.
And by the time you're done, it'll have
made you a fortune.
And what happens?
How do you actually exit that trade?
You don't, you'll just get stopped out.
You just keep going.
Make sense?
Every target is a soft target.
And what will happen in that situation?
After you've been stopped out and you
enter that trade into your Kelly
criterion,
your R score is going to go through the
roof.
And what have you done for the next six,
12 months?
You've just given yourself license to
continue trading like an animal.
Because your R score has just gone through
the roof.
That's what you've got to do.
So put every trade you do in the Kelly
criterion.
Start off with self-imposed position
limits.
But those position limits are soft.
Only when winners emerge are you allowed
to break limits.
You never break limits on a loser.
Ever.
Monitor your Kelly criterion, your K
score.
And if you ever go for interviews, print
off your track record of all the trades
you've ever done.
And staple your K score on the front.
And leave it with the guy or the person
that's just interviewed you.
Interviewed you.
And if you've done a couple of hundred
trades, you've got an R of around two.
And your K score is 23-25%.
Your W is 50.
And you've got an R of around two.
And your K score is 23-25%.
Your W is 50.
And you've got an R of around two.
And your K score is 23-25%.
Your W is 50.
Whoever it is is going to be pretty
impressed.
And if you've got an R of around two.
And your K score is 23-25%.
Your W is 50.
Whoever it is is going to be pretty
impressed.
And if you've got an R of around two.
And if you've done a couple of hundred
trades, you've got an R of around two.
And your K score is 23-25%.
Your W is 50.
Whoever it is is going to be pretty
impressed.
If you do that, it's worth as much as your
degree on your CV.
And in the process, you'll probably pay
for your degree.
That's what you've got to do.
So you know when to deploy capital to
yourself and when not to.
Now what happens if you get to the end of
year one.
And you've got a good W.
Got a good R.
And got a good K score.
You want to be putting more money in your
trading account.
Box A.
You're good at trading.
So why are you limiting yourself?
Shoot for the moon.
And you'll fall amongst the stars.
You're selling yourself short.
Take more risk.
Because you've got a stop loss portfolio
anyway.
So it doesn't matter.
You might as well take more risk.
But if it goes wrong, you better trade out
at the stop loss portfolio.
I've seen nightmare situations where guys
have gone from 20,000 pounds in their
trading account to over 300,000 pounds in
a year.
And by the end of year two, they're at
zero.
Because they didn't put risk management
parameters on their portfolio.
Okay, welcome back.
So what you saw there was the Kelly
Criterion.
And the Kelly Criterion is a metric which
you use.
And most importantly, you use it as a
metric to tell you, firstly, what you
should be deploying to yourself in terms
of capital.
So we've been through the risk management
parameters.
And we first looked at gross exposure
limits and single position limits.
Well, the Kelly Criterion also gives you a
good awareness statistic which tells you
overall whether you're just a good or a
bad trader.
Now, if you're a good trader and you're
winning, you should be pulling from box A.
You should be taking more risk.
How do you take more risk?
You do it twofold.
You either increase exposure in your
trading account and or you add more money
to your trading account further down the
line.
So for example, if you open the trading
account with $25,000 deposited on margin
and your exposure was $100,000 to $125,000
to begin with.
So four to five times.
And over, let's say, an eight month
period, you were pretty consistent and you
managed to double your $25,000 to $50,000.
So that would mean, based on your exposure
levels, you're getting a 20% to 25% return
on your money and doing this net of
commission on a consistent basis.
Let's say you've done this over an eight
to 12 month period.
Well, what's happening here?
You're probably being told at this time by
the Kelly Criterion that you're pretty
good at trading and also your profit is
telling you that you're pretty good at
trading.
So you should be pulling from box A here.
You should be increasing your exposure
levels and you should be thinking about
putting more money in your trading
account.
Now, what do we do if you get the
opposite?
Let's say you're losing money
consistently.
Well, you're just going to hit one of your
portfolio construction parameters, which
is stop losses on your positions and stop
losses on your overall portfolio.
And your stop losses are there so you can
actually preserve capital and try again.
So you don't necessarily have to take
money out of your trading account.
It will just mean that overall you've been
bad at trading over that time period.
And your W is going to be bad and your R
is going to be bad, which means a
combination of your winning probability
factor, your W and your risk management
capabilities, your R.
A combination of those just means that
you're bad.
So pulling from box A and pulling from box
B, that's what Kelly is going to show you.
And that's what you're going to do when
you start out properly as a professional
portfolio manager or taking this approach.
Second thing that's important with the
Kelly criterion is the ability to identify
what your strengths and weaknesses are.
So if your W is really good, so your ideas
are good, but your risk management is very
poor, then it's obvious that you need to
work on your risk management and you need
to increase R.
You need to work on making that a better
number.
Also, if your risk management is very
good, but your ideas are poor, it's very
obvious that you need to spend more time.
You need to put a bit more effort into
generating higher quality ideas.
But also at the gatekeeping side, you
might want to try and time these trades
better or with your price action
indicators, make sure you're taking the
correct approach.
So it can come in the whole idea
generation phase, but also with
gatekeeping.
So if your W is bad, that's what you need
to be focusing on.
Now that we've been through the Kelly
criterion and the self-awareness statistic
that is very important, what you need to
understand as well is that with your
portfolio construction parameters, if the
Kelly criterion is recommending that you
do more on a single position, on a single
trade in your portfolio versus what your
own percentage limits are on your single
position assets.
You probably should not be going above
your own self-administered statistics.
So for example, the Kelly criterion is
recommending that your next trade or a
single position should be a maximum of 15
or 20%.
That's all fine.
That's good to know.
But if your limits are 10% in your own
portfolio, you should stick to them
because you don't want to be investing too
much money into one position or one idea.
Your own position limits stop you from
being overconfident and putting too much
money into one idea.
So the Kelly criterion, if it's
recommending more, that's great.
Just keep it in the background.
Keep the Kelly criterion running.
You should absolutely overlay it with your
own risk management parameters.
So we've been through all this stuff now.
We've been through having discipline one,
two, three and four.
And doing that, we went through training
psychology.
Make sure you understand that.
Make sure you've got the foundations
correct.
Try to deploy the box A and the box B
strategy into other areas of your life.
This is the mode of thinking of a trader.
And this is the mode of thinking that you
have to get used to.
Secondly, we looked at portfolio
construction parameters.
Definitely deploy some or all of those
parameters into your portfolio.
If you don't, you're just falling into the
trap of being an amateur trader.
And that's something you don't want.
You need to protect your downside.
You protect your downside because you
understand the psychology.
And you understand your weaknesses as a
human.
We also looked at the hedging techniques.
We've been through beta.
You can use the basic beta approach.
You can also use the advanced approach.
If your objective is to work at an
investment bank or a hedge fund.
And we've also been through the
self-awareness statistic of the Kelly
criterion.
So you know at any one point in time how
good you are as a trader.
And your own abilities as a trader.
So you can deploy capital to yourself
responsibly.
So we've been through the whole of risk
management now.
We're going to move on to the next video.
Make sure you go through the risk
management and self-awareness statistic,
the Kelly criterion, over a number of
times before you actually start committing
capital to real trades and building a
portfolio.
It's very important stuff and will
separate good traders from bad traders.
And you obviously want to be a good trader
that makes money consistently over time.
If you don't do these things you simply
won't be.
So please make sure you go through these
videos many times.
I'll see you in the next video.